[Music]
victoria is with us in pennsylvania hi
victoria welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up in your world
well you see so we just uh discovered
you me and my boyfriend probably this
week and we're looking to make my
emergency fund and i have a trust fund
that probably has i'm gonna stay
probably about thirty thousand dollars
in it uh but the only issue is my mom is
the
i'm gonna say like the holder of the
account right now
she's not really giving me access to it
since i became
over the age of 21 now i'm 22.
she's making it pretty difficult to
access that money so we were looking
just to get it out so we can start the
emergency fund
what are the terms of the trust
so it was originally made for schooling
but i've already had my degree and they
made me
she actually had me pay out of pocket
for that whole degree because she didn't
want to touch the money
so i was probably about five thousand
dollars that i spent on schooling
but she won't let me touch any of that
you have a copy of the trust
um i have the information i've actually
been in contact with the trust and they
were just like hey she just has to sign
this paper and then it goes into your
name
and she will not do it because she
thinks i'm going to be a
quote-unquote stupid kid and blow all
the money
okay the but the terms of the trust say
that it's to revert to you controls to
revert to you at 21.
oh yeah but because i was underage when
it was made she just won't find it over
no no no stop you're not underage now
right the terms of the trust say that
the money is to be turned over to you
after age 21 correct yep and she just
has to she doesn't have to sign anything
she doesn't have to sign anything
okay get back in touch with the trust
company and tell them you're going to
contact a lawyer and sue their butts if
they don't turn your money over to you
okay
she's no longer a trustee of a trust
that is now defunct because you turned
21.
okay
i'm not a lawyer but that's if you if
you have a lawyer look at this situation
that's what they're going to tell you
yeah that's going to be the next step we
were just trying to figure out if that
was the right step or just trying to get
her to sign it over would be the best
step well i mean
best step would be that she doesn't need
to sign it because of the terms of the
trust
and if you've actually reviewed them uh
i would get in touch with the trust
company and go uh the terms of the trust
are that it's 21 it's turned over to me
there's no signature required on her
part if you don't turn it over to me i'm
contacting legal counsel so you need to
do this right now
yeah describe them and just have them
send you the money and that solves the
whole thing you call your mom up and
tell her what you did
yeah she's trying to exercise control
over something she no longer has control
over what i'm saying
yep especially since i moved out she
does not have nothing to do with moving
out of me has nothing to do with moving
out the terms of trust don't state you
have to live with her they don't state
you whether you live they don't state
where you live they state where you're
that you're 21 period
yeah
okay
if you go do something stupid with this
money you ought to have your butt kicked
yeah i do
okay
you go screw this up if you go screw
this up you ought to have your butt
kicked but that doesn't change the fact
that legally you have right to this
money
yeah based on what you are telling me if
you have correct information
yeah i
should probably just uh go over the
trust and specifically what it says and
if
it just says 21 then they should either
write me a check or
or
we're going to have an attorney contact
them and tell them to do that yeah
yeah
and uh then you can call mom and say mom
i've i've retained legal counsel because
you're illegally holding this
and you need to sign the paper and turn
it over to me now
well there you go that's an easier
answer said than done
well it is and
thus is the problem but yeah
that's the deal hey thanks for the call
i hope that's all that information's
right because i don't know your
situation but it does sound like you
need to you need legal advice
uh once you've gone through the details
of the trust if you can't get mom to
release it to you and you think the
trust says it's to be released to you
and based on what you're telling me
that's my advice to you so good question
thanks for the call
okay so here's the rule ken um
nothing wrong with doing a trust
and it's not unusual to do a trust for a
minor
until they turn 21
and at 21 is turned over to them and
sometimes it's later it's turned over to
them
uh the mistake that was made in this
situation was
um
they appointed someone to be the trustee
who did not have the
the intellectual power to do it
because mom is trying to function like
mother and not trustee and it's gonna
get mom sued yeah
yeah
uh so you can't you you can be a mother
and you can have motherly opinions and i
might even agree with her mother maybe
victoria doesn't need this money maybe
she's acting out maybe she's immature
maybe she's going to blow it i already
told her not to blow it right just like
her mom would have told her right but
but those instincts are different than
the actual legality of a trust a trustee
is only allowed
to do what the trust states
correct they're not allowed to insert
their own opinion
or advice into the situation unless the
trust states that yeah
in which case you have really opened up
a pandora's box of a mess i was curious
what you thought about what we heard
here now i think it's fair that victoria
i don't know that she's read the fine
print i don't think she's going to which
is great but
does it strike you as odd that the trust
would say to her well we need a
signature from mom you would think or is
this a bad assumption on my part that
they know what it actually says and they
were in fact telling her what isn't what
is in fact true
i truly have no idea why a trust company
would be unless they're just out of an
abundance of caution trying to keep mama
happy right they don't want mama coming
back after him too right she's going to
be pissed when this goes down yeah so
that's my guess is they're just trying
to play politics here rather than
legalities which they're going to get
their
tail on a crack too yeah
that's going to be a problem so the
problem is when you assign a trustee
then the trustee
uh you know what there's no trust there
is no trust company she's the trustee
yeah so something she's she must have
gone to a bank account and a banker told
her that that's what i'm wondering like
because that struck me as odd yeah
what you have to do then victoria is
take a copy of the trust into the bank
right and show the branch manager look
this is what it says and the every
minute that you hold this past this
you're going to be liable
yeah and just [ __ ] that's what i was
wondering because the trust is just the
document that says here's the deal that
manages
sometimes there's a trust company but
the trust company i mean the trust
department the bank can act as a trustee
exactly but the mama's the trustee on
this no question and she's mad that
victoria left the house yeah according
to victoria so didn't like the boy
yeah same but and all of that may be
accurate
doesn't matter though in this case well
all that matters is so point being that
the takeaway for all of you in america
is if you're going to form a trust be
careful who you appoint as the trustee
it is a tremendous responsibility
and they can get themselves into a
problem if they start inserting their
own
opinions
into the application of the legality of
the trust